this past weekend a video went viral of
a Catholic nun throwing out the first
pitch at a White Sox game Singh went
everywhere it's actually pretty
impressive
check it out yeah yeah pretty cool now
and this is absolutely true I'm about to
say some people are questioning the
timing of the video people out there
saying it may have been a calculated
stunt to distract from the recent
scandal in the Catholic Church now I
don't know they may have a point because
as more allegations came out another non
video went viral take a look at this one
that's the non climbing Chicago's Willis
Tower right there people were very
suspicious why is she doing this it was
an incredible stunt but again timing
timing suspicious but this Catholic
Church scandal is not going away so yet
another video of a nun came out just
today check this one out I was just
really good yeah yeah you have to wonder
are all these distractions calculated to
show the Catholic Church in a more
positive upbeat way I don't know for
sure
I think it
[Music]
this is what I'm talking about do not
that's enough do not look at the nun
juggling chainsaws it's just a
distraction that's all it is and
gentlemen please turn your attention to
extreme BMX team the sisters of no mercy
[Applause]
no no no Andy do not fall for this and
no these stunts are amazing let's focus
on the real issues okay real issues that
we have to talk about tonight for
example starve the AMC series better
call Saul Bob Odenkirk is on the program
[Applause]
the TBS series words that craigers here
[Applause]
if you get Shooter Jennings is here got
more show coming up
[Applause]
you